[Music]
hey guys
welcome to another installment of harry
potter theory
in this video we're going to be
discussing albus dumbledore
the potters lord voldemort and one
fateful october evening
that would reshape the wizarding world
for years to come
james potter was one of the marauders
and a member of the order of the phoenix
during the first wizarding war
and because of this he held certain
established relationships
with people whom he felt he could trust
when the fabled prophecy foretold the
birth of a boy
that held the power to vanquish the dark
lord voldemort
the potter family who had just given
birth to baby harry
had to go into hiding in order to secure
their hidden location
the potter family didn't tell anyone
where they were hiding except for one
person
peter pettigrew pettigrew was made the
secret keeper for the potter family
a secret keeper is a witch or wizard
designated to hide a secret
secured by the fidelity's charm which
conceals the secret inside of the secret
keeper's soul
sirius black was the initial choice for
secret keeper but sirius
thinking that voldemort might target him
suggested that they choose pettigrew
instead
the following excerpt from sirius
addresses this
lily and james only made you secret
keeper because i suggested it
i thought it was the perfect plan
voldemort would be sure to come after me
would never dream they'd use a weak
talentless thing like you
it must have been the finest moment of
your miserable life telling voldemort
you could hand him the potters
after being made secret keeper peter
pettigrew revealed his true colours
and in one infamous act of cowardice and
disloyalty
revealed the location the potter cottage
to voldemort not even a week after he
was made secret keeper
it was then that voldemort seeking out
the potters in an attempt to stop sybil
trolloni's prophecy from coming true
travelled there with one goal in mind
kill the boy
when he entered the potter residence he
quickly put an end to james potter
and then started making his way towards
lilly and baby harry
voldemort then killed lily and next
advanced towards harry
letting out one final avada kadavra
however
what voldemort didn't know was that this
would be the last offensive spell he
would conjure
for quite some time as the spell
rebounded and deflected back at him
this marked the end of the first
wizarding war and the end of lord
voldemort
for a while at least while the temporary
defeat of voldemort was a blessing for
the wizarding world
i can't help but speculate on the whole
situation as i feel that it surely could
have been avoided altogether
first of all why would the potters hide
in such an obvious place
a big house in godric's hollow seems
like a far cry from an actual hiding
spot
regardless of whether or not fidelity's
charm was involved however my biggest
issue with the whole situation
was that dumbledore was never selected
as secret keeper dumbledore is arguably
the most powerful wizard of all time
and he was an ally of the potters so to
me he seems the obvious choice
as secret keeper he wouldn't have even
needed to be secretive about it
as even lord voldemort feared dumbledore
in fact he was the only person that he
ever feared
this is supported with the following
quote from mcgonagall to dumbledore
but you're different everyone knows
you're the only one you know
all right voldemort was frightened of if
dumbledore had been secret keeper it
would have ensured that the potters were
safe
so why didn't that happen why would they
choose peter
pettigrew in the prisoner of azkaban
it's revealed that dumbledore even
offered
to take on the responsibility james
potter told dumbledore that black would
die
rather than tell where they were that
black was planning to go into hiding
himself
and yet dumbledore remained worried i
remember him offering to be the potter's
secret keeper himself
this means that even though dumbledore
offered james potter's blind trust in
sirius black and his friends
whom he deeply trusted was his eventual
downfall
dumbledore was close with james but he
wasn't one of the marauders
and james felt that he could truly trust
his friends more than anyone
and that if he made one of them secret
keeper he would never have anything to
worry about
another reason that dumbledore may not
have been chosen was the fact that he
was
so high profile and they may not have
wanted to make such an obvious choice
however it certainly would have been the
right choice given dumbledore's immense
levels of power
and one final reason that dumbledore may
not have been selected was his new
relationship with snape
snape came to dumbledore when he learned
that harry was the target of the attack
and presumably this prompted the use of
the fidelius charm in the first place
this means that by this point dumbledore
had accepted that snape had switched
sides
however his new relationship with snape
may even still doubt in his other allies
as it's unlikely that people were
particularly welcoming of snape
they preferred to go with someone that
they were completely familiar with
and that was their ultimate downfall and
that's it for this video
if you enjoy the content please like the
video and subscribe to the channel
we've added a join button recently and
in addition to our regular upload
schedule
we'll be producing member-only content
and updates
so if you want to support the channel
further please consider checking it out
until next time your wizard harry